let's see if we can take the derivative
with respect to x
of 2 to the x
2 to the x power and you might say hold
on a second we know how to take the
derivative of e to the x but what about
a base like 2 we don't know what to do
with 2. and the key here is is to write
rewrite 2 to the x so that we
essentially have it as e to some power
and the key there is to rewrite 2. so
how can we rewrite 2 so it is e to some
power
well let's think about what e
let's think about what e to the natural
log of 2 power is the natural log of 2
is the power that i would have to raise
e to to get to 2. so if we actually
raise e to that power
we are going to get to 2. so we could do
instead of writing 2 to the x we could
rewrite this as e
we could rewrite 2 as e to the natural
log of 2
e to the natural log of 2 and then raise
that to the x power so this is the x
power in yellow this is the x power in
yellow and so let's do that right over
here so instead of taking the derivative
with respect to x of 2 to the x
let's say let's just take the derivative
with respect to x of the exact same
expression rewritten
of e
to the natural log of 2
e to the natural log of 2
raised to the x power
raised to the x power let me put this x
in that same color
dx
now we know from our exponent properties
if we raise something to some power and
then raise that to another power we can
take the product of the two powers let
me rewrite this just remember if i have
a
to the b and then i raise that to the c
power this is the exact same thing as a
to the b
times c power so we can utilize this
exponent prod that exponent property
right here to rewrite
this as being equal to the derivative
with respect to x
of
e
to the natural log of 2 times x
e to the natural log of 2
times x
times x and what's neat about this is
now we got this into a form of e to the
something so we can essentially use the
chain rule to evaluate this so this
derivative is going to be equal to the
derivative of e to the something with
respect to that something
well the derivative of e to the
something with respect to that something
is just e to that something so it's
going to be equal to e
to the natural log of 2
times x
so let me make it clear what i just did
here this right over here is the
derivative
of
e
to the natural log of two
times x
with respect to
the natural log of two let me make it a
little bit clearer with respect to the
natural log of 2
times x so we took the derivative of e
to the something with respect to that
something that's this right here it's
just e to that something
and then
we're going to multiply that by and this
is just an application of the chain rule
of the derivative of that something with
respect to x so the derivative of
natural log of 2 times x with respect to
x is just going to be natural log of 2.
this is just going to be natural log of
2. the derivative of a times x is just
going to be equal to a this is just the
coefficient on the x and just to be
clear this is the derivative of natural
log of 2
times x
with
respect to x so we're essentially done
but we can simplify this even further
this thing right over here can be
rewritten and let me draw a line here
just to make it clear that this equal
sign is a continuation from what we did
up there but this e to the natural log
of 2x we can rewrite that using this
exact same exponent property as e
to the natural log of 2 to the natural
log of 2 and then all of that raised
raised to the x power
raised to the x power and of course
we're multiplying it times the natural
log of 2.
so times the natural log of 2. well what
is e to the natural log of 2 well we
already figured that out that is exactly
equal to 2.
this right over here is equal to 2. and
so now we can simplify this whole thing
the derivative of 2 to the x is equal to
and i'll switch the order a little bit
it is the natural log of 2 that's this
part right over here times 2 to the x
times 2 to the x or we could write it as
2 to the x times the natural log
of
2.